euromaxx highlights and here's your host
colleen hempstead greetings from berlin
and a warm welcome to our highlights of
the past week lining up this time with
the following stores chilling out we
visit the world's first ice hotel in
school
light and shadow we check out the
haunting installations of Christine and
Davey McGuire Atlantic escaped
picturesque funchal on madera is a huge
tourist draw and we start off with
catspaw kovarsky who is no ordinary
photographer and that's because when he
clicks the shutter he's dangling
somewhere in midair either in a
paraglider or in a gyrocopter the
37-year old specializes in aerial
photography in the rather maverick way
that he goes about it adds an unexpected
dynamic to his shots while for his
unusual perspectives of his polish
homeland he's already won a long list of
prizes and awards and so we met up with
him to see how he gets the job done
magic an autumn forest in a cashew bein
region in northern Poland graphic a snow
covered storage facility near Gdansk
mysterious the city of San dolmetsch
during a flood abstract landscapes
captured from a bird's-eye view with a
digital single-lens reflex camera that's
the trademark of Polish photographer
kacper Kovalsky
I'm just taking the simple observation
from above those pictures are about
features of our civilization so this is
like a portrait of civilization on
example of Polish landscapes Kowalski
worked as an architect for four years
then he decided to pursue his two great
passions flying and photography he quit
his job and began taking professional
aerial photographs whenever he can
Kowalski flies over his country in a
gyroplane an open-cockpit mini
helicopter he has to prepare his flights
carefully and do regular maintenance on
the aircraft sometimes it's a long wait
before the light and the weather are
right the weather is unpredictable and
the forecast was good and we should able
to fly but it's raining so so I can fly
but it will be the same pleasure like
riding motorcycle in the rain so you can
do it but it's not comfortable once he's
up in the sky it's a kind of meditation
another world accessible only from the
air opens up
the 37-year old photographer revisits
some sites again and again in different
seasons or at different times a day like
this beach on Poland's Baltic Sea coast
Kowalski's pictures tell little stories
about the relationship between humans
and nature when I will see some feature
of human activation it can be at the
beach in the forest in the winter some
sign imprinted in the landscape then
this is the interesting thing for me and
humans leaves traces all the time and
this is amazing Kowalski has always been
interested in places that are difficult
to find and access industrial facilities
chemical plants opencast mines he flies
over them and photographs things that no
one would otherwise see in 2014 he
received a World Press award for a
selection of these pictures that he
titled toxic beauty I wanted to show the
people places that are like a cost of
our comfortable life because we have
energy in the cable in our house and
this means that somewhere this energy
should be have to be produced toxic
beauty shows those places those places
that we would like to push out from our
imagination and our our emotions
the interface between humans and
landscape is the focus of Kowalski's new
book called side effects he consciously
left out any explanations of the photos
beyond their GPS coordinates and this is
the similar situation that I have during
my flight because I fly above the ground
I see the landscape and there is no
caption on the ground and this is the
situation of discovering places with me
I can somebody can fly with me through
my book cats / Kowalski's way of looking
at things turns every day landscapes
into little stories and sometimes into
riddles in April and exhibition of his
new pictures will open in New York a
central heating is one of those mod cons
that as far as I'm concerned is
indispensable in the winter time and yet
there are plenty of people who would
happily spend a night in the deep freeze
and even pay for the experience the ice
hotel in Yucca Chevy in northern Sweden
is one place that they go to do it it
got started 25 years ago and since then
numerous other ice hotels have of course
sprung up in many parts of the world but
none of them really quite measures up to
the original
it's winter in northern Sweden 200
kilometres north of the Arctic Circle on
erlend is crossing the frozen torna
River on her way to the village of Yoko
CRV and the world's first and biggest
ice hotel the photographer has an
especially close relationship to this
place for years she supervised the
people who reshaped the hotel every
season and she was an ice artist herself
in 2013 she published a photo book about
the logic
for me the combination between the very
friendly warm people and the really cold
environment of snow and ice that
combination that creates magic and I
decided to make a book about it because
I wanted to show the rest of the world
what I what I feel how much I feel for
this place each of the approximately 60
ice rooms has been individually designed
by artist light designers do their part
to set the stage in each room everything
here is made of ice or snow except the
mattresses and reindeer furs on the beds
the ice hotel is open from december
until mid-april and draws 50,000
visitors each year the architecture is
beautiful and it's very cold but it's
nice yeah like it it was really cool
super amazing our first time here and
you know in Taiwan we don't have snow so
we were so exciting it's one of my
dramatically the day my dreams come true
ice is gorgeous so it makes everything
look good
each year from october to December a
crew of about 100 builds the Ice Hotel
anew they use about 5,000 tons of ice
and snow artists from around the world
annually submit more than 100 designs
hoping to be given the task of creating
one of the rooms on Erlin had her chance
in 2012
it's really really hard work you don't
work from 85 you work from seven till 12
in the night time usually so it's 24 7
and when you're done with your room or
your art than you you're also done as an
artist the history of the ice hotel
began in 1989 ice artists at a workshop
built an igloo to use as a bar after a
night of partying some of the guests
slept in it a success story was born now
there are many imitators around the
world one example is the Soros neva
igloo hotel in northern Norway this is
its 16th season only a little newer is
the line yo snow village in Finland here
even the restaurant is made of ice
nice hotels are not limited to the
Arctic either some of these crystal
palace's are in the Alps or the Pyrenees
the snow hotel grand Valera in Andorra
even offers its guests of whirlpool in
the middle of the ice but the ice hotel
in yo casi RV still has the most guests
one very important thing is the Tana
River of course it's a very clean water
way yes that aside here it's runs very
very slowly in a very good way so the
ice will be of the best high quality and
also one of the most important things we
have always trying to do something new
and we put a lot of effort on the art a
night in the ice hotel costs about two
hundred thirty euros most visitors spend
only one night in a nice room like on
Ellen they spend the rest of their stay
in the area in typical Swedish wooden
houses in the evening Anna seeks out the
ice hotels own Chapel for her it's this
year's ice hotels most beautiful room
this is the hotel's ice bar the hotel
itself has kept on developing over the
past 25 years when people think of
Sweden the thing go on Stockholm and the
ice hotel now there are so many tourists
coming to to this area and that makes
the people can work here people can live
here as I think that's really really
important the temperature inside all the
ice rooms is five below zero Celsius but
that's cozy almost toasty compared to
the 20 below outside the walls of ice
well for several years now it's been one
of the hottest trends in winter sports
free-riding otherwise known as skiing
and snowboarding off piste and as the
ultimate expression of freedom it's
certainly not uncontroversial because of
the potential dangers and environmental
damage and yet every year the number of
free riders does grow while some ski
resorts are now catering specifically to
this group and one of them is kitzbühel
in Austria it just hosted its second
annual freeride weeks and that's a
gathering that is never short on thrills
the kitzbühel alps are one of the most
popular places to ski in the world more
and more winter sports enthusiasts are
choosing to ski or snowboard down runs
into the valley here that are off the
designated piece Austrian Martin Vincula
has been skiing off-piste since he was a
boy today he's a star of the free riding
seen Frankie Linda Duffman out in the
open you can do whatever you want that's
quite rare in our society and probably
why it's so fascinating you're your own
boss the rules are written by nature but
that's it sounds kinda Martin Vincula
passes on his passion and knowledge when
he holds workshops during the freeride
weeks at the moment he's working with a
number of veteran free riders he shows
them how to find the safest and most
scenic line or route through the terrain
while ensuring the skiers take care now
to disturb the animals or damaged young
trees along the way for vinca the most
important thing is that the participants
respect the mountains the snow is never
completely predictable even for
professionals so everyone needs to be
constantly aware of the danger of
avalanche sleazy cooker you can't remove
the risk so we always need emergency
equipment with us I was listening to buy
hub part of the basic equipment is an
electronic device that helps find skiers
trapped after an avalanche before
they're shoveled out this Avalanche
probe is used to determine the victims
precise position an inflatable rucksack
that helps you stay above the snow
during an avalanche is a vital piece of
equipment kitzbühel only established
itself as a free rider area in recent
years the freeride week set up by
Austrians Matias Maya and Matias how
holla entice people here from all over
the world free riders now make up thirty
percent of the winter guests here
this sir by the extensive area offers a
lot of possibilities for free-riding
it's not just sloping Meadows for
beginners but stuff for professionals to
suborn with philatelic after buying
going with this trend we naturally
appeal to a younger age public that we
wouldn't otherwise have had in kid
spirit in kids beneath hatin after
winning numerous international freestyle
competitions as a youngster martin ving
club began concentrating more on
filmmaking in 2006 it's important for
his sponsors to get images he travels to
all corners of the globe including to
the mountains of Alaska or to the
Argentinian volcanoes
middle cove or the slave it's a
documentary about a freewheeling life
you don't influence the story but shoot
cinematically using beautiful angles and
shots shannon ang diliman martin Vincula
is also a juror for the film competition
held during free ride weeks the entries
are mainly about the most exciting free
rides rather than aesthetics fabien
Lynch was selected the latest champion
for his spectacular ride between the
trees
all my measurements my filipina good at
the top I had my doubts I stood there
and considered whether i should do it or
not but then i thought it'll be fine as
soon as you start you don't think
anymore you're completely focused that's
the beautiful thing about skiing and
free-riding just skiing and staying
healthy and enjoying life possibly my
creativity being close to nature and the
feeling of freedom all contribute to
people's growing fascination with free
riding
just imagine their poor mothers well
we're off to Bristol now in the UK to
meet Davy and Christine McGuire he grew
up in London she comes from the former
East Germany his background his film and
theatre and hers is dance and
choreography which is why it's somewhat
surprising perhaps that they found a
common creative ground with something as
simple as paper but put all of those
things together and you get some
award-winning paper theatre
installations
you
the hunter a theatrical installation in
the setting made of paper the character
is torn between his obsession for
hunting and his love of animals the
intricate paper diorama comes to life
through projected animations music and
sound effects Kristen and Davy McGuire
have been working together for around 10
years they develop the stories create
the sets and also perform in their works
we want to create our own little worlds
and we're lucky enough that other people
like to sort of take that journey with
us you know what I mean well I think
it's a childhood thing their first paper
hard work the ice book dates back to
2009 the story only comes to life when
the stage lights come on the Haunted
dress was commissioned by the Royal
Shakespeare Company it uses theatre
costumes projections and sound to tell
the story of an evil fairy queen it's
magical but also a little spooky like
all good fairy tales the artists use all
kinds of techniques to bring their ideas
to life we have this vision and we just
want to make it what whatever it takes
if it means that we have to learn how to
cut paper we have to learn how to use
certain software then we just go and do
that Christine McGuire was born in
Germany and used to be a dancer she's
her husband Davey as a Sri Lankan
background and grew up in London he
studied film and theatre they created a
video installation to tell the story of
how they met chasing dreams in our
hearts
she said they knew from the start that
they wanted to live and work together
but there were some differences at first
yeah when I first met Christine she's
very frank because I'm joke is this a
German finger but that's interesting
because British people tend to be a bit
more diplomatic about things and then
let something get to a point where they
should have discussed it much earlier
and I think and then it becomes a big
problem whereas Christine just puts me
down all the time and I get used to it
like some of the sinister element
doesn't they've made a name for
themselves in the art world in London
gallery owner Sarah long is an admirer
we've had our young British artists like
Damien Hirst and you know sarah lucas
and they're sort of ironical cynical
reaction to life and here's the
Maguire's with this sort of rather
childlike approach which is very
refreshing their work is also lucrative
these light installations such as the
miniature fairy in a preserving jar can
fetch over 4,000 euros in London and New
York in the real world Kristen and David
McGuire sometimes find it hard to stop
working we had a strict policy of like
not talking about work after six o'clock
for a week we did it I think we've got
two weeks but on the other hand it's
great we've been invited all around the
world and it's just us traveling with
each other which is really really nice
the couple combined the traditional
fairy tale with modern technology to
create a magical world of light and
shadows and finally the Portuguese
island of Madeira lies about seven
hundred and thirty kilometers off the
coast of Morocco and so it enjoys very
moderate temperatures all year round on
the name of its capital city funchal
comes from the portuguese word for
fennel which sailors found growing there
when they discovered the island way back
in the early 15th century while today
it's an oasis of rich vegetation and of
course the perfect destination for Sun
staff tourists
when sean is the capital of the island
of Madeira it overlooks the Atlantic the
city's origins lie here in the
historical city center Santa Maria
mayara over the years this neighborhood
fell into disrepair until locals decided
to have numerous facades doors and
entrances revamped by artists today this
street is one of the most attractive
destinations in the city
the Omaha coming to get it till it's a
street with a lot of character and
what's more poetry which question of
science some of these buildings date
back to 18th century this is a street
where you can sit outside there is one
other since they repainted all the doors
this has become a street where it's a
joy to stroll look out the Brazil it per
se when Charlotte's famous market is
located on the outskirts of the old city
if you visit is about pietà you'll begin
to understand why madeira is called the
island of flowers then with this little
late Thursday vintage we have many
flowers and so many wonderful things to
see in all the world there's no market
like ours here in Madeira the market is
certainly one of the most popular places
in the city visitors are drawn by the
exotic fruits that they're invited to
taste
which on is home to more than a hundred
thousand people to the west its streets
are a little wider perfect for an
afternoon stroll to discover a good
street side cafe
there are small parks around every
corner just out of the center there are
even parks where you can live in hotels
surrounded by their own green oasis the
quinta de casa branca is a five-star
residence located on the site of a
former banana plantation this is maderas
first designer hotel it has 43 rooms
overlooking about a hectare of
subtropical gardens reads Palace is
perched on cliffs that plunge down into
the sea it's an elegant hotel steeped in
tradition he first opened its doors at
the end of the 19th century and has
played host to many prominent guests
including British Prime Minister Winston
Churchill
and Irish playwright George Bernard Shaw
tea time on the terrace of one of the
highlights it feeds here you'll find a
vast array of desserts and sandwiches to
choose from and every day at three p.m.
guests can choose from a selection of 12
different kinds of tea plants and trees
thrive in the mild climate here the
sumptuous gardens of the patio estate
500 metres above sea level are a
spectacular sight it's private property
but visitors are welcomed the garden was
started in the early eighteen hundred by
the konica vial and was sold and bought
by my husband's great-great-grandfather
in 1885 and since then all the
generations of women have been tending
to the gardens here you'll find flowers
from all over the world the estate has
belonged to the Blandy family for
generations they've done well thanks to
their Madeira wines the family's wine
cellar in the centre of funchal is also
worth a visit there are plenty of guided
tours and wine tastings here Madeira is
a fortified wine similar to port or
sherry it's left to ferment in oak
barrels before being transferred to
bottles we have a dry wine which is
produced with a grey pooled sociale a
medium dry which is with a great value
medium rich which is wall and the rich
which is the momsie
some visitors explore when shot and its
surroundings on foot while others prefer
to take in the sights from the cable
cars that slowly travel up into the city
the view is just as lovely on the way
down but this might be the most
entertaining way to descend in a wicker
sleigh it takes just 10 minutes to glide
down the two kilometer slope making the
unique ride just one of many fun things
to do in fern shot
and on that bombing note it is time for
us to sign off so until we meet again
all the best from us here in Berlin and
thanks very much for watching choose
alpha design and bye-bye
you